yeah yeah yeah dude I'm right here I'm  right here man yeah bad eye  bad idea bad idea  isn't that me I can take the next person  right here 750i I will take one ticket  for the matinee please you actually just  cut everybody in lines so sorry no I was  part of that group so yeah I'm part of  waiting in line and I'll just take one  ticket student discount make it easy sir  um oh yes uh we are together too please  rate I'm gonna strip next  mm-hmm that's a line okay thank you for  your service sir  did you just cut my line did you do da  this one talk about this way sorry got  caught on this stop it's stuck on my  backpack  I gotta go I've got a meeting okay hey  it's going good everyone's really nice  they've been really welcoming like  there's this one like really tall guy  and he like he keeps talking to me and  like this weird voice and my girlfriend  are weird but whatever these nice  enjoy the show  one ticket please we're actually sold  out